das ist wirklich der wahre horror dieser
wurm frisst und frisst und frisst ohne
dabei selbst gefressen zu werden und in
frankreich handelt es sich schon jetzt
um eine wahre invasion die rede ist vom
plattform mit der bezeichnung obama nun
gar der sich von anderen würmern und
schnecken ernährt und somit die
ökosysteme enorm bedroht fachleute sind
geschockt über das ausmaß seiner
verbreitung und nichts scheint die
killer wärme aufhalten zu können
pixum 2004 gibt es spannendes seien sie
das abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur dann verpasst er nichts
los geht's herzlich willkommen
das könnte der stoff für einen neuen
horrorfilm sein denn tatsächlich findet
in frankreich derzeit eine invasion der
kieler firma statt es handelt sich um
einen plattwurm der wahrscheinlich
bereits vor einigen jahren durch die
globalisierung eingeschleppt wurde obama
nun gar wird maximal zehn zentimeter
lang und ist typisch für einen wurm halt
bräunlich und vor allem schleimig seinen
namen hat er übrigens nicht dem ex us
präsidenten barack obama zu verdanken
stattdessen wurde seine bezeichnung aus
einer alten südamerikanischen sprache
abgeleitet hier steht opa für blatt und
führt ihr das große problem jedenfalls
bei obama nun gare handelt es sich um
ein fleischfresser und der wurm ernährt
sich am liebsten von anderen würmern
insekten und schnecken und genau das
macht forschungsteams weltweit große
sorgen denn diese tiere übernehmen eine
wichtige rolle für die ökosysteme würmer
beispielsweise sorgen für die lockerung
des bodens und kompostieren das
herbstlaub doch genau diese lebewesen
hat obermann und ghana im visier
zudem nimmt seine anzahl überhand in
einer großen studie berichtet ein
französisches forschungsteam jetzt dass
diese plattwürmern fast ganz frankreich
heimisch geworden sind
auf dem europäischen festland wurde er
mittlerweile in 72 der 96 französischen
département aufgespürt dabei ist der vor
allem an der atlantikküste weit
verbreitet in einem garten hatten die
fachleute sogar mehr als 100 exemplare
aufgespürt behilflich waren ihnen dabei
tausende garten besitzerinnen und
besitzer die an dem großen wurm projekt
teilgenommen hatten und der wissenschaft
jeden wurm fund gemeldet hatten
der neuen studie zufolge stammt obama
wohl aus argentinien und wurde
höchstwahrscheinlich über boden substrat
von pflanzen die in südamerika
gesichtet wurden verbreitet
möglicherweise sogar in alle welt und
nicht nur nach frankreich was die
fachleute aber sicher wissen die würmer
mögen vor allem gemäßigtes klima und
genau deswegen fühlen sie sich an der
französischen atlantikküste sowohl
extreme hitze kälte oder aber dürre
marco bahmann und ghana dagegen gar
nicht das französische forschungs team
offenbarte in der aktuellen studie aber
nicht nur dass der killer wurm nun in
frankreich heimisch ist die fachleute
können auch erklären warum sich die
würmer so schnell ausbreiten konnten
zum einen vermehrt sich der wurm rasant
schnell und zum anderen fehlen hier in
europa die natürlichen fressfeinde vögel
beispielsweise halten abstand da obama
nun gara chemische abwehrwaffen einsetzt
und das macht ihn für andere tiere
ungeniessbar frist also und frisst und
frisst ohne selbst gefressen zu werden
hinzu kommt die würmer gelten als die
dritte invasive wurmt dieser
fleischfressenden spezies die sich alle
in europa ausbreiten dennoch gilt obama
nun gar als die größte gefahr
möglicherweise kann der wurm auch
deutschland befallen der neben den
meisten kunden an mittelmeer und
atlantik küste wurde barbara vor allem
auch im elsass nahe der deutschen grenze
gemeldet auch in belgien italien und
spanien beispielsweise wurden die würmer
schon gesichtet schaurige parasiten
vernachlässigte krankheiten anklicken
anschauen und kurz gesagt abonnieren
sehr sehr cooler kanal bei funk bis dann
bleib dran